[Music]
in luxor's karnak temple colleen is
hunting for clues that explain ramsay's
rise to power
ramses was a mighty warrior and general
who fought in many campaigns and
expanded egypt's borders to the east and
south
but the temple walls suggest that's not
the only reason he became so powerful
this is a remarkable document it's the
actual text to a peace treaty
this 3 300 year old wall holds 38 lines
of hieroglyphic inscriptions that lay
out in detail the world's first peace
treaty
an unprecedented promise of alliance
between ramses and his mortal enemies
the hittites
it's amazing to see the text of an
actual treaty this is the document that
two great powers signed
egypt on one hand and the hittites on
the other this proves that ramses didn't
just fight wars
he ended them too
peace allowed egypt to prosper and for
ramses to get richer and more powerful
this tells us how neither the hittites
nor the egyptians could attack one
another and if they were attacked by a
third party they would come to their
allies aid
the egyptian hittite peace treaty or the
treaty of kadesh meant ramses could
finally end his 20-year war with the
hittites wars are quite costly so by
having peace ramses is guaranteeing
stability and prosperity in his reign
this allowed ramses to focus on
gathering wealth and building temples
and monuments that celebrated his mighty
achievements
a lot of pharaohs including ramses used
propaganda but in the case of the peace
treaty these are real terms with a real
foreign king so this shows ramsay's
wanted everyone to know that he was a
great diplomat
ramses demonstrated himself to be the
ultimate king
and his choice of karnak to proclaim as
such was no accident
i think ramses is showing the peace
treaty here at karnak precisely to
contrast with his military exploits he
does what he needs to do to preserve
order on behalf of egypt's gods
ramses was a warrior king and a diplomat
who ruled over an extraordinary period
of peace and prosperity
[Music]
[Music]
you